you
[Music]
in the dressing room something happens
while I'm getting ready once I start
putting my makeup on I turn from this
male to female and that is amazing for
me
[Music]
my name is Cassandra luxottica
I am a professional wrestler I've been
wrestling for 28 years I'm an exotic
Oulu teller which is a flamboyant
wrestler with glamour and style
[Music]
[Applause]
I always knew I was different I remember
when I was in second grade I think I was
like 7 or 8 years old and I already knew
I was I was gay I was taught that I
couldn't be gay I couldn't act this way
I couldn't dress this way I couldn't
talk this way because I was gonna burn
in hell when I was first called to be an
exotic car I was like wow
freedom this weight that I've been
carrying for years was just like melted
down in the dark I started using the
pantyhose
the makeup the bathing suits rhinestone
feathers and boas and all that because I
wanted to be different and that was the
scariest moment but when I saw the
audience and the fans how they took me
in they were just like wow look at him
her.she I feel like a woman inside
and then it's like this is me and that
transformation is beautiful something
happens when I get out of the dressing
room to the ring I'm still looking like
a woman I'm looking flamboyant and then
once I step in the ring my macho sigh
kicks in my mighty gotta be ready for
the fight all my subtle matches and
mostly all of my matches have been
against men
masked man like G stars homophobe eggs
and I thought always be true to myself
it's Lucha Libre you're not a beauty
parlor even though it looks like it
sometimes today I can tell you that
being gay has been a gift from God to me
and I understand that so that's why
Lucha Libre has always been one of my
biggest medications I I don't think I
will ever leave Mussolini this is what
I've done all my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
some people may think how can it be that
somebody can be both gay and a cowboy
because cowboy is the model of the macho
masculine man that it doesn't matter
whether you're a man or a woman whether
you're all butch or Nelly everybody can
find a place within our community within
our rodeo circuit that's what we are
[Music]
my name is Bruce Crowe and I'm the
president of the International gay rodeo
Association
we're celebrating our 30th anniversary
of our finals review today cowboys and
cowgirls compete in 13 events so that
the best of the best are represented in
our sport at this event today my name is
Greg PJ I'm an all-around cowboy and I'm
gay I grew up on the Navajo reservation
being on the reservation you kind of
find things to do and rodeo was one of
them gay rodeo is more than just a
celebration I think it's a place for
people to be comfortable I don't have to
worry about hiding anything
[Music]
years ago professional Cowboys looked
upon us as mocking their sport as
they've come to know us more they come
to appreciate and understand the fact
that we embrace the same sport they do
we may express it a little bit
differently but we still have the same
passion and dedication to being good
competitors good cowboys and cowgirls
that they do gay rodeo offers a few
different events that traditional rodeo
doesn't we offer wild drag race and go
dressing in our rodeo men and women can
compete in every event equally we were
gonna see men in drag I don't know that
when people really come to know us
they're gonna find a more warm
supportive friendly experience than
they'll find here with us gay rodeo is a
safe space for people to be accepted
with each other I've established a rodeo
family here I can always count on people
and they can count on me
[Music]
you get your hair done you can't be
touched
you're just you're on point for at least
48 hours the queer community needs a
safe space to get haircuts and that's
part of the reason why I'm here
my name is des Marshall I'm a barber I
work in Brooklyn New York
the barber shop I work at it's called
the gamesman it's kind of an institution
here in downtown Brooklyn the owner
Frank has been here for over 50 years
the clientele has been a lot of men who
working in the neighborhood
it's a lot of lawyers a lot of judges
other types of businessmen I kind of
throw a wrench into a little bit I mix
it up a little bit my clientele is
mostly queer trans gender non-conforming
folks of color non folks of color for
the most part my clientele is the LGBTQ
community I think with barbershops
it's difficult as a woman in to walk in
the can sometimes just feel like a boys
club it's nice to feel like you can let
your hair down get it off I think I'm
building a bridge in different ways can
you be at 5:00 3:30 I got you for queer
folks to trans folks are gender
non-conforming folks hair is very
important you keep it really crisp or
more rounded got you but you need a
barber that you feel comfortable to talk
to about how you want to look what's
that vision that you have someone who
can execute it but also do it in a way
that they're not gonna be judging you
throughout the whole process
I get to spend my day with other queer
folks in a space that you know twenty
years ago we probably couldn't even walk
walked into you know I'm part of that
story now my clients are a part of that
story now we're part of the history of
this place we're part of its legacy and
that's it's really cool
[Music]
I'm Eric Mason I'm a mother and I'm a
transgender guy Koree is my 15 year old
transgender daughter I started
transitioning almost two years ago and
Corey started transitioning almost five
years ago I've always known that I was
different
I've always known that I'm not the
normal boy I was never like happy I was
always negative when I first put on some
makeup I was like my family is made up
of me my husband and my five children I
waited until Cory was completely through
her transition before I came out myself
it was really hard keeping that secret
from my family especially for my husband
but at the time I just knew I had to
focus on my child
I've been boy since fifth grade and
still getting boy sometimes when kids
said I should go and kill myself because
that I was different
[Music]
when my mom came out I was like I'm not
alone anymore we can actually understand
what we're going through with each other
we can you know talk to each other for
having a bad day me supporting Lori is
in my opinion what you're supposed to do
as a parent you're supposed to support
your children no matter what so I don't
feel like I did anything special I
didn't I just love my kid I love my kid
no matter what she looks like no matter
who she wants to be we are stronger as a
family I think anytime you are living
your authentic self and you are living
your truth it makes you a better person
overall it makes you a better parent it
makes you a better spouse my family is
everything we fight we laugh we cry
we're a typical family we just look a
little different that's it it's all
boils down to
you
[Music]
the beach is not a very safe space
anyone can relate to feeling
uncomfortable on the beach
men women queer otherwise and it's also
a very gendered space like the moment
you put your toes in the sand you know
it and you feel it and you know that you
have to kind of pick one side of the
spectrum either you're more on the
masculine side or you're more on the
feminine side what does that do for
everyone that doesn't exist on one clear
side or the other
[Music]
I am re Fitz and I run a fashion project
called tomboyish in so many ways aims to
tackle the way that we see beauty and
the way that we see masculinity and
femininity a couple years ago I really
started to balance my own masculinity
and femininity and I felt really good
and I felt like myself I wanted to help
other people get there - to me getting
dressed in the morning is kind of like
putting on my suit of armor as a queer
person as a woman as a person of color I
feel like there are so many things in
this world that wants to silence us
silenced me minimize me and minimize my
experience in this world what we choose
to wear signifies that we are here we
are present and we're not gonna be
silenced we're not going anywhere so the
project I'm working on is a really dope
super hot lookbook that features all
things swimwear for those who don't
exist on the hyper masculine side of the
hyper feminine side like myself because
I know what it feels like to step out on
the beach and not feel confident
we have to get creative we have to find
items that most of the time you wouldn't
really think are like swimwear or
beachwear pieces and we have to make
them ours swim vests also body suits and
then from there just accessorize it's a
beach it's meant to be fun it's meant to
be light it's summer the stress and the
trauma that people experience when they
go to a beach is just like it's so
unnecessary the more I can do to just
get that out of the way and and make the
beach fun again that means that my job
is on do you boo just rock it just make
sure you're like rocking it with like
you know some God whenever you got it
[Music]
you
[Music]